so this data was taken from the
publication modeling precision treatment
of breast cancer which was featured in
genome biology in 2013 and produced by
researchers at a company called
genentech the publication is interesting
because the authors assembled a data set
of about 50 different breast cancer cell
lines that represent the whole spectrum
of breast cancer variations the cell
lines have genomic transcriptomic and
proteomic data as well as an efficacy
measurement of commonly used and
experimental cancer drugs
if we look in the paper abstract we can
find relevant terms to this project
molecular profiles selecting features
specific to each subtype of patients and
a use case for various machine learning
methods to find answers about efficacy
of drug treatments for the right
patients
this brings me to this flow chart that
places our analysis into perspective
when we analyze data we want to answer a
question the question leads into the
data set which has to be prepared
before we even get the analysis step
or answer any of the questions we need
to know what data we are dealing with
what are its properties and how does it
describe the conditions that we are
interested in
in the next few lessons you will learn
about this type of data and the way we
can explore such data using data
visualization statistical analysis and
machine learning in python ultimately
you will see how analysis of
transcriptomic genomic or metagenomic
data can lead to important answers posed
in this publication and many other
similar projects